qui n'a jamais rêvé de devenir invisible
être le meilleur des espions savoir ce
que vos proches pensent réellement de
vous ou même cambrioler une banque en
1995 deux braqueurs tentent le coup ils
attaquent de banques à visage découvert
souris même au caméras normal il se
pensent invisible pour préparer leur
coup ils se font frotter le visage avec
du jus de citron on me voit on me voit
plus c'était censé les faire disparaître
au caméra il y avait l'idée on se sert
du jus de citron pour écrire des
messages car l'acide citrique qu'il
contient est invisible en approchant une
flamme il va s'oxyer et changer de
couleur pour faire apparaître le message
le jus de citron ne fait pas disparaître
c'est lui qui sert d'encre d'ailleurs
l'oignon le lait ou l'urine ont des
propriétés similaires heureusement
qu'ils ont commencé avec le citron ils
auraient pu éviter de braquer une banque
investir intelligemment s'il connaissait
notre partenaire yomoni une équipe de
pros de la finance oublier les
placements RAR dans les banques
traditionnel déjà gros avantage c'est
que vous pouvez dire bye bye la
paperasse tout se passe en ligne si vous
avez des questions hop un conseiller en
ligne et là pour vous éclairer c'est
simple rapide et ça vous épargne de
longues heures dans une banque à
attendre votre tour le truc cool c'est
que vous avez le contrôle vous décidez
de combien vous voulez investir chaque
mois vous pouvez choisir votre niveau de
risque que ça soit pépè ou plus
téméraire vous pouvez même opter pour
des placacements écoesponsable et tout
ça avec des frais ultra compétitifs
seulement 1,6 % contre 3,6 % ailleurs ah
et si vous vous demandez si c'est un
coup de poker détrompez-vous votre
argent entre de bonnes mains géré par
des experts et des robot advisers et
bien sûr il y a les performances passées
pour vous rassurer je sais ce que vous
dites l'argent c'est chiant et bien
yomoni vous facilite la vie vous pouvez
automatiser vos versements votre argent
travaille tout seul dans 20 ans vous
serereit bien content d'avoir investi
car comme on dit l'argent qui dort c'est
de l'argent qui se dévalue alors pour
ceux d'entre vous qui sont déjà dans le
game je vous conseille de jeter un œil à
yomoni vous pouvez même simuler
gratuitement votre investissement sur
leur propre site le lien est dans la
description personnellement j'utilise
yomoni depuis 2019 je ne peux que vous
le recommander alors n'hésitez pas à
faire une simulation sur yomoni.fr
n'attendez plus prenez le contrôle de
vos investissements et investissez avec
yomoni peut-on créer une capâ
d'invisibilité depuis Harry Potter tout
le monde veut la sienne et les vidéos
pululent sur les réseaux en 2017 on
annonce même que le gouvernement chinois
en a créé évidemment ce sont des fakes
une simple cap verte ou bleu un logiciel
de montage et hop on y voit que du feu
pourtant l'université de Koo au Japon
ils l'ont fait cette cape tout
simplement une caméra filme le décor qui
est ensuite projeté sur la cape ça
fonctionne comme au cinéma et c'est bien
ça le problème si l'écran n'est pas
devant le projecteur pas de film si on
part se balader plus rien n'apparaît sur
la CAP il faudrait amener la caméra
l'ordinateur et le projecteur partout
niveau discrétion on a vu mieux deux
informaticiens italiens ont retourné le
problème cette fois on ne projette rien
sur la cape c'est elle qui a M l'image
il faudrait donc un tissu recouvert
d'écran LED flexible mais également de
microocaméra pour filmer l'environnement
à 360° la conception coûterait un peu
moins d'un demi million d'euros le
braquage a intérêt à bien se passer pour
la rentabilisé l'argent n'est pas le
seul problème l'informatique peut vite
devenir un frein à la création un écran
cassé ou un morceau de ciel qui apparaît
au milieu de votre camouflage et fini
l'infiltration si deux caméras pointent
dans la même direction le résultat
risque d'être étrange le décor
apparaîtrait en double ou serait déformé
pour éviter cela un logiciel doit
connaître la position de chaque caméra
en temps réel et leur direction ainsi la
perspective peut-être numériquement
corrigée pour correspondre à la réalité
c'est la coordination des images le
souci c'est que le décor et la cape
bougent tous ces mouvements sont
imprévisibles et autant de corrections
demandent beaucoup de bandes passantes
s'il n'y en a pas assez le logiciel
n'arrivera pas à gérer toutes les
données l'image sera saccadée pas très
discret ils estiment que le défi est
trop important pour le moment le concept
ne fonctionne pas pour une cap mais il
peut quand même être utilisé le principe
reste le même mais cette fois on équipe
un bâtiment tout en entier 453 m de haut
une invisibilité totale la nuit je vous
présente la crystal top Tower des
caméras grandantang réparties sur
plusieurs étages retransmettront en
direct l'autre face du bâtiment sur des
écrans LED les premiers et les derniers
étages de la tour seront inclinés ce qui
déformera l'image un logiciel sera donc
chargé de corriger numériquement le
rendu elle doit voir le jour en Corée en
2024 près de l'aéroport de inchen mais
depuis son annonce en 2014 plus de
nouvelles pourtant la construction
semble bien avoir commencé si
l'informatique ne peut pas nous aider à
devenir invisible voyons comment les
autres sciences pourrai y arriver
comment peut-on s'inspirer de la nature
en 2000 le monde découvrait Alba une
lapine albinos qui a la particularité
d'être fluorescente c'est dû à l'ajout
d'une protéine bien spécifique la
protéine fluorescente verte sans
déconner tout est faux ou presque
l'artiste à l'origine de la photo a
découvert les lapins génétiquement
modifiés en visitant les labos de linra
il a voulu en garder un pour le montrer
au monde et n'a pas beaucoup aimé le
refus à partir de là il raconte qu'il
s'agit de l'œuvre de sa vie et de son
idée il retouche une photo de lapin et
le voilà célèbre et oui car Alba ne
brille pas vraiment la protéine n'est
fluécente que sous l'AMP puvé de toute
façon elle a été découverte en 1962 la
même année que la naissance de l'artiste
précoce le petit génie elle est sécrétée
dans les cellule de la Méduse éera
Victoria ce qui vaudra d'ailleurs le
prix Nobel de chimie à son découvreur le
rapport avec l'invisibilité d'autres
gènes ont été étudiés notamment chez les
poupes et les sèches où les
scientifiques ont découvert la
réflectine cette protéine a la
particularité de changer forme pour
modifier le comportement de la lumière
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire que ceci
selon le milieu qu'elle traverse la
lumière ne réagit pas de la même manière
par exemple elle se dépasse plus vite
dans l'air que dans l'eau et plus vite
dans l'eau que dans le diamant c'est ce
qu'on appelle l'indice de réfraction en
passant dans des milieux avec deux
indices différents elle va ralentir ou
accélérer c'est ce changement de vitesse
qui va dévier l'image un phénomène que
vous avez déjà observé quand vous mettez
un bateau dans l'eau il semble tordu
c'est parce que son image voyage plus
vite dans l'air que dans l'eau pour
devenir invisible il faut donc se
rapprocher le plus possible de l'indice
de l'air c'est ce que fait la protéine
en changeant de forme elle peut donc
devenir opaque ou complètement
transparente une équipe de l'Université
de Californie a cherché à l'intégrer à
des cellules humaines en modifiant leur
ADN elles sont capables de sécréter la
protéine elle peut donc se rendre
invisible leur étude a permis la
création d'un modèle informatique grâce
à ça ils peuvent prédire les quantités
de réflectine et les conditions
nécessaires pour faire disparaître une
cellule la découverte date seulement de
mars 2023 mais peut-être que bientôt
nous pourrons devenir des hommes poupes
et disparaître dans le décor car en plus
de se fondre dans le décor ils sont
également capables d'imiter le relief
c'est ce qu'étudie une équipe de
l'université de cornel ils utilisent une
peau en silicone ultra extensible
contenant des sphères gonflables ce sont
elles qui vont imiter le relief en se
remplissant d'air pour contrôler la
forme du relief elles sont recouvertes
d'un maillage c'est comme si vous
mettiez un fil autour d'un ballon en
gonflant il ne sera pas rond mais suivra
la forme que le fil lui impose cela leur
a permis de donner à la peau une forme
de plante ou de pierres leur but est de
créer des robots camouflés afin
d'étudier les animaux dans la nature
mais ça présente un autre intérêt
camoufler des véhicules ou des drones le
camouflage est primordial dans l'armée
pourtant il n'a vu le jour que durant la
Première Guerre mondiale un artiste
français sur le front a eu l'idée de
cacher l'artillerie sous des toiles
peintes en suivant son héritage l'armée
française a lancé le projet caméléon
initié par la DGA en 2012 son objectif
est de reproduire la capacité de
camouflage d'un caméléon plein de
petites écailles contenant des pigments
de couleur dont la concentration peut
varier pour changer de teinte les
possibilités sont quasi infinies et
c'est l'objectif de l'armée le véhicule
est recouvert de pas lumineux et d'un
système optique capable d'étudier
l'environnement on peut ainsi changer de
couleur de façon optimale et disparaître
c'est ce qu'on appelle le camouflage
actif le système est beaucoup moins
lourd que pour une cape d'invisibilité
ici pas de reproduction fidèle du décor
on veut juste se camoufler en changeant
de couleur pour l'instant le projet a
abouti sur un panneau de 3 m² qui a été
à l'essai toute cette année le but étant
de savoir si le système peut résister à
la pluie au sable ou même au choc mais
le projet se veut encore plus ambitieux
l'utilisation d'affichage souple afin de
les fixer directement sur un textile
plus complexe il ne faut pas que le
poids gêne les soldats durant leur
déplacement ils estiment produire un
premier prototype de tenue pour 2030 ça
le rendrait même invisible aux
infrarouges de son côté le Royaume-Uni a
lancé le projet adaptive des tuiles
contrôlées indépendamment et pouvant
ajuster leur température en copiant
celle de l'environnement rendant
invisible aux caméras thermiques elles
peuvent même être utilisées pour le ré
l'ennemi en modifiant l'empreinte
thermique d'un véhicule ou transmettant
des messages la chimie peut-elle vous
faire disparaître dans l'homme invisible
de 1897 l'antihéros utilise des produits
chimiques pour réduire l'indice de
réfraction de sa peau bien sûr il s'agit
d'un livre mais ce genre de technique
existe à notre époque il s'agit du
procédé clarity développé à l'université
de yonsey en Corée le but rendre
invisibles les différents tissus d'un
être vivant et c'est beaucoup de boulot
les organes vont être prélevés puis
immerger dans un fixateur comme le
formaldide le but va être de tuer toutes
les cellules oui oui il va se greffer
aux protéines et aux composants
cellulair stoppant toute activité
biologique quel est l'intérêt dans ce
cas il empêche leur dégradation une fois
fixé c'est un organe peut-être étudié
durant des années si cette étape n'avait
pas lieu les produits suivants le
détruiraient ils sont ensuite plongés
dans un bain contenant de l'acrylamide
et d'autres produits chimiques qui vont
pénétrer les tissus en se logeant entre
les cellules ils vont réagir pour former
un gel c'est lui qui permettra à la
structure de ne pas s'effondrer une fois
le processus terminé vient enfin l'étape
la plus importante rendre l'organe
transparent pour y arriver il va nous
falloir éliminer tous les lipides ce
sont eux qui causent l'opacité pour
faire simple si vous mettez de l'huile
et de l'eau ils ne se mélangeront pas
car l'huile et est hydrophobe elle
repousse l'eau pourtant on peut voir à
travers les deux liquides maintenant si
vous les mélanger en secourant très fort
vous allez créer ce qu'on appelle une
émulsion des petites d'huile en
suspension dans l'eau mais le mélange
est devenu totalement opaque c'est parce
que l'indice de réfraction entre l'eau
et l'huile est trop différent comme il
ne se mélange pas la lumière est déviée
en rencontrant une bille d'huile pour
être dirigée vers une autre bille qui la
dévie à son tour elle reste donc bloquée
à l'intérieur du mélange dans nos
organes c'est pareil ils vont donc être
perfusés avec des solvants qui
solubilisent les grisse cette étape dure
plusieurs semaines mais au final on
obtient des organes qui ressemblent à ça
et ça fonctionne avec toutes les parties
du corps même les EAU bien sûr
impossible de devenir invisible comme ça
non seulement les cellules ne
fonctionnent plus mais sans lipide
impossible de rester en vie l'expérience
n'a jamais été réalisé sur un humain
décédé mais elle fonctionnerait le
rendant totalement transparent peut-on
créer un matériau invisible hypertils
biotechnologie vous connaissez non
pourtant vous connaissez leurs produits
il y a 4 ans il dévoileent le quantum
steels 80 € sur Amazon l'invisibilité à
porté de main mais comment c'est
possible le procédé est ingénieux car il
se sert d'une technologie que vous
connaissez tous et que vous avez tous eu
entre les mains les cartes en relief la
feuille est parcourue de lentill en
forme de tube qui vont renvoyer la
lumière dans une seule direction en
fonction de notre position on voit une
image ou l'autre ici le rouge ou le vert
on appelle ça l'imagerie lanticulaire
dans le cas de Quantum steels le procédé
est légèrement détourné mais le principe
reste le même le bouclier est parcouru
dans toutes les largeurs de lentille
c'est cylindrique à cause de leur forme
toute lumière qui la traverse va être
étirée et déformée on le voit très bien
avec ce laser l'image de tout ce qui est
derrière le bouclier est donc moins
intense et finit par être recouverte par
celle du décor en plus de cela la forme
de l'objet et des lentilles dévie la
lumière de certaines zones tout ce qui
s'y trouve passe hors de portée d'une
personne face au bouclier une version
géante est à l'étude pour camoufler des
véhicules voire un bâtiment entier
l'illusion n'est pas parfaite mais le
résultat reste quand même efficace si on
reste immobile par exemple serez-vous
capable de retrouver le bouclier sur
cette image il est là une fois vu
impossible de le rater mais les quelques
secondes nécessaires pour le repérer
peuvent se montrer cruciales dans
certaines missions d'infiltration il y a
quand même un défaut tout ce qui est
perpendiculaire aux lentilles est
camouflé mais tout ce qui est parallèle
est visible vous cherchez à fuire un
tueur à votre rousse vous vous cachez
derrière le bouclier mais vous le mettez
dans le mauvais sens çaen est fini de
vous d'autres matériaux pouvant nous
aider à devenir invisible sont les
nanotubes de carbone en les soumettant à
une chaleur intense on obtient ça c'est
le même principe que sur la route l'été
l'air proche du goudron étant très chaud
il dévie la lumière en étant déviée elle
va refléter le ciel c'est un mirage
lorsqu'on avance dans le désert et que
l'on voit de l'eau c'est en fait le ciel
qui se réflète sur l'air proche du sable
ici la température va modifier l'indice
de réfraction du liquide autour des
tubes la lumière accélère et elle est
déviée on pourrait donc créer des
mirages de poche derrière les cas
disparaître ça y est on tient notre
secret de l'invisibilité si vous voulez
vous en servir il va falloir résister à
plus de 2000°gr et ça risque de ne pas
être simple mais surtout la chauff
doitre être brève sinon tout l'air
autour de vous va chauffer c'est la
différence de température qui crée le
mirage plus de différence plus
d'invisibilité avec les nouveaux
matériaux qui sont créés comme les méta
matériaux la science de demain nous
réserve encore beaucoup de surpris on
n'est pas à l'abri de voir apparaître
des lapins invisibles dans les
prochaines années ou bien il musk
construire une armure résistante à la
chaleur pour disparaître ce qui est sûr
c'est que ce vieux rêve pourrait bientôt
être à notre portée n'oubliez pas
d'aller cliquer sur le lien de notre
partenaire yomoni nous on se retrouve
très vite pour une prochaine vidéo sur
la suite de mon bac+ 8 Ciao